- But your Christmas special
airs tonight NBC, right?
- Yeah, and it's great.
- Are you excited?
(audience applauding)
I love doing Christmas specials.
Look at all that talent on the stage.
- I know, it's great.
- Yes!
- It's a great show.
I was able to put in some of the hits
and the Christmas songs,
and you don't even know
which one is coming.
And it's really great.
- Oh, I like that.
- Yeah.
- Oh, that's really cool to do
because people always want,
yeah, they always wanna
hear like the hits as well,
so that's really smart.
- Yeah.
- I'm not that smart.
I've never done that.
(Barry laughing)
But we heard that they
wouldn't let you have puppies,
that you wanted puppies.
- Well, yeah.
How did you know that?
- I know.
Well, I like puppies.
- I've got everything.
It snows on the audience,
and there's presents, and there's trees.
And I thought...
And little children.
The little kids come running
out, and Santa Claus.
- Magical.
- Everything.
So we had everything.
And I said, "Gee, wouldn't it be great
if we had like a puppy for
one of the little kids?"
- Wouldn't it be great?
Let's bring Barry a puppy.
He didn't get a puppy.
(audience cheering)
We've got puppies.
(jingle bells ringing)
Look at these cute, cute puppies.
(audience cheering)
(Barry laughing)
Oh my God.
Could I hold one?
- Oh my goodness.
- This is Spot.
(Kelly screaming)
- Oh, how old?
- This is Tiny.
- Oh my goodness.
- Hello.
What's your name?
Oh, you little...
- Barry, this is dangerous.
I do not need another dog.
Oh my God, everybody, I should
mention these puppies are
Spot and Tiny from the
Brixies Rescue Center.
And you can find out how you
can adopt them or their friends
by heading to our show's
Instagram stories.
You're sweet.
(audience exclaiming)
Hello.
- I think she recognizes me.
- [Kelly] See, she did.
She was like-
- Do you have all my albums?
- "Mandy" is her favorite.
You're trying to get to my coffee, bruh.
Nah.
(audience laughing)
I hear that you actually ended
up breaking Elvis's record
in Vegas with the most live shows, right?
- That was great.
It it was an honor.
- That's insane.
- It really was an honor.
(audience cheering)
- 'Cause any time people think of Vegas,
you think of Elvis and
all those live shows.
- Yeah.
- And you have trumped him, I like it.
- Yeah, and you know, on
that day I sang "Hound Dog?"
- [Kelly] Oh, did you?
- Me singing "Hound Dog?"
- Why not?
- And I jiggled around
a little bit, like...
- Yeah.
(audience laughing)
I like it.
You gotta jiggle a little, it's Elvis.
Oh, they're like crying.
Do you wanna go run around?
Maybe they wanna run around.
I don't know.
- Should we do it?
- Do you want down or do you want...
Do you want down?
- You want go down?
- We're gonna let 'em down.
Let 'em free.
Let 'em be free.
- Okay.
Okay, ready?
- Here we go.
- Ready, run!
- Go have fun.
- Okay.
- They're gonna be peeing
all over this place.
(audience laughing)
- Ready, pee!
- Yeah, go!
(all laughing)
They're like, this is mine, this is mine.
So while they're marking
their territory...
Oh my God, they're so cute.
I really don't need another dog, Barry.